images of treatment sensitive breast
cancer cell lines cultured with bone
marrow micro environment
firstly let's understand the disease
what is breast cancer breast cancer
growth is an infection that makes the
cells of the breast become unreasonably
large breast cancer growth is
characterized into various
classifications it most regularly starts
in the pipelines or lobules this disease
can possibly spread to different
locations of the body by means of the
blood and lymph vessels
breast disease side effects fluctuate
from one individual to another certain
individuals have no apparent signs or
side effects coming up next are some
breast disease
symptoms or signs an unfit not a lump in
the breast or underarm expanding or
thickening of a breast
but dimpling or bothering off the breast
skin
flaky skin
all the science does not actually point
towards breast cancer it can be due to
other reasons also
now how is breast cancer treated breast
cancer can be treated in different ways
some of them are surgery chemotherapy
radiotherapy etc
being a lady and
being more established are two
significant factors that increase your
risk of breast cancer most of the breast
cancer growths are analyzed in ladies
beyond 50 years old
other variables are smoking exposure to
cancer-causing chemicals and changes in
other hormones related to night shift
employment can also raise your risk
inherited breast cancers are fair
accounting for about five ten percent of
all malignant seasons inherited breast
cancer arises when limitations or
abnormalities are passed down from the
parent to the child within a family
now coming to our topic
what is the gene signature a g signature
or
which is also known as a gene expression
signature is a single of combined
collection of genes in a cell that
exhibits a distant pattern of gene
expression as a result
of a changed or unmodified biological
processes or a pathogenic medical
condition
disease transcription signatures have
the potential to be used for two
different purposes diagnosing a
patient's disease status and prognosis
thus guiding treatment decisions and
gaining insights into business
mechanisms
the purpose of the following project or
the research work is to find the genes
that are mainly responsible for
perceiving breast cancer
and also to find the gene expression
function and the positive analysis of
those differentially expressed genes
found
for this particular work i used various
data sets
various methods and techniques and also
the t by info server
the three techniques that we use for
this project are the rna sequence
analysis normalization pca technique and
differentiation analysis and thus their
respective pipelines to get the output
results
this slide shows us the data sets used
and the samples
[Music]
let's move on to the methodology used
the data set was taken from the ncbi
site it was based on the p62 isophone
with alternative splicing enhances chemo
resistance in breast cancer the
organism was homo sapien a total of 20
samples were present in the data set
data from 10 pre and post nac breast
cancer sample pairs were used to create
the overall design the type of samples
present was sra and the source from
which it was taken was the breast cancer
tissue i downloaded the required files
of the sample data from the particular
data
for my project
let's know about what's pipeline a
pipeline
is a workflow with interconnected
processes that each take the output of
the preceding step
fixing mistakes and greats cleaning out
undesirable technical
variations mapping on genome on
transcriptome and organizing raw leads
into genes and iso forms are all part of
this workflow which uses specific file
formats to structure data in a
step-by-step way
here we use a total of three pipelines
this slide shows the screenshot of the
first pipeline that was ran
the name of the first pipeline is the
rna sequence pipeline
a sample of rna is converted to a cdna
library
which is subsequently sequenced and
mapped against the reference genome in
rna sequence it also gives information
on alternative slicing and non-folding
rna in addition to the capacity to
assess gene expression levels such as
micro rna rna sequence analysis can
reveal biological information
on changes
in gene expression levels gene structure
and splicing patterns so for this reason
this pipeline is used
now let's move on to the steps
and also understand each element of the
pipeline first step is start the rn
sequence analysis pipeline begins with
the task name start merges user selected
data input choices into seeker sequence
of tags and creates the appropriate
pipeline option
pre-processing raw readings comes next
once you start your pipeline we are
doing two pre-processing stages
first is the disconnect the adapters and
second is pcr duplicates are removed
now moving on to the second step that is
primomatic adapters were added to
readings during the rna sequencing
process
module in this pipeline removes such
adapters the trimomatic program
removes technical adapters from raw
sequencing greens trimmermatic
pre-processing is typically used to
improve the quality of ring alignment on
the reference reload
the third step is the pcr cleaning
easier clean module means generally
copy
for users from crude sequencing
information
input designs for the module are fast
queue or fasta
sequencing for users in the wake of
naming pcr copies the result is given in
a similar organization as information
that can be either first cue or fasted
the fourth step is mapping or the
alignment of clean ways from reference
hero
clean and pre-process the raw sequencing
reads the readings will then be mapped
to the reference genome
as a result mapping software will be
emphasized from the readings we are
using the brownie t2 tool
the ground
is a modified version of the brown 22
algorithm that maps transcripts
it is a fast alignment algorithm based
on the seed technique
fifth step is the quantification of rna
expression
once you've successfully mapped your
readings to the reference genome the
measurement of rna expression value is
the next step the rn expression
measurement approach
approach
include selfish or rsa we'll create an
rna expression table with fpkm values
using the rsem or
same expression table technique
the rsem software tool may be used to
calculate genes and isoform abundances
from single end or pair and rna sequence
data the last step is to end the
pipeline
when the expression quantification is
finished finally at the top right side
of the interface select the end option
to conclude this pipeline so pi pipeline
multiplier server
server in my case took roughly around
four to five days to be complete
the next slide shows as a screenshot of
the second pipeline that we run
the name of the second pipeline is the
quantile normalization pipeline with pcm
we examine the influence of
normalization on an inputted file data
before calculating vsa components the
data is noticeably more clear and simple
to deal with after normalization that is
it reduces a number the number of
factors or components derived through
pca is smaller than the initial number
of variables in this case the threes
this is why we perform this
the steps and the elements are explained
below the first step is start to begin
go to the top menu and choose area of
analysis then data mining utilities
click upload files to approve the gene
expression file generated in the
previous step
simply submit the gene expression file
in this case
on the pop-up click start then okay
step is select quantize normalization a
window will emerge with the title
parameters
convert the table to ln and set the
threshold to 5.0 choose yes in the next
option select save in the next
you can now choose to stop your analysis
at
quantile normalization but we are going
to keep on going with the pca
the third step is to generate pca
components select pca components to
generate pca component
you can also use the pcr library that
can produce visualization plot in pdf
file i chose the default settings here
you can experiment with the parameters
to see what happens
the last is to end
to choose the pop-up
click end and save then name your
pipeline
this slide shows us the screenshot of
the third pipeline
the name of the third pipeline is the
differential expression pipeline it is
essential to realize that we should
utilize a particular arrangement of
information while running this sort of
investigation that's why we do this
particular step examine the relevant
genes from the rna expression data a
variety of methods or algorithms can be
used
steps and elements under this pipeline
are the first
is start to do differential expression
analysis go to the t by info servers
data mining section and click the
differential expression option
then comes file upload when you select
differential expression
you will be sent to the file code page
the second step is grouping of the
samples after information transfer try
to drag the examples
that try to drag the samples into
gatherings it is essential to recall
what was your group b and your group
in my situation the untreated samples
are in group one and the treated samples
are in good two
the third step is to perform
differential gene expression analysis
using d set two
choose a decentral module when you take
differential gene expression analysis
when you click reset 2 a box will appear
asking you to define or specify the
parameters
the fourth step is to perform enrichment
analysis of significant genes for
biological annotation
we use enrichment analysis and g
spa that is the gene set enrichment
analysis to figure out what the
biological implications of the important
genes are
we figure out what relevant pathways are
significant genes are enriched in based
on the engagement analysis
when you choose the enrichment analysis
module a pop-up window will appear
allowing you to set the parameters
the fifth step is to perform gstf
when you click on the gse analysis
module you will get a pop-up similar to
the enrichment analysis module where you
can set or define your parameters
the last step is to end name and run
your pipeline and the pipeline click on
the end button
then name the pipeline lastly
click on the run on clusters to run the
pipeline
let's look at the results that we got
after running
all the three pipelines
the rna sequence analysis pipeline
results
this method generates a gene expression
file that includes gene ids gene
expression and anticipated counts for eg
below is the visual to the file that we
obtained
the next is the normalization pca
pipeline results
the yellow dots on the pc graph which
you can see on the right side
[Music]
indicates treated samples whereas the
gray points represent the untreated
samples
the pca plot does not show
significant separation and it does not
cover or explain a large number of
variation this is because according to
the statistics we see one which is 16.4
percent and pca2 which is 12.48 percent
which combined do not even cover 30
and similarly pc1 pc2 and pc3 together
do not even cover 40
so we can say that because the pc plot
does not cover even half of the data
distribution we cannot infer or make a
conclusion based on it as a result we
proceeded with the differential gene
analysis to obtain the gene list
now
the differential gene analysis results
after finishing the third pipeline
the first would be the visual
representation of the differentially
expressed genes
using a volcano plot the second
dseg all dot text file which is a
tabular representation of the
differentially expressed gene and last
is the enrichment and gse plots
now let's talk about
first the dsec all text file this
provides us with important information
for each gene such as the p adjusted
value which should be less than 0.05 to
determine if the gene is substantially
differentially expressed or not to
determine if a gene is constitutively
upregulated law of the foreign value
should be greater than or equal to 1.5
and significantly the down regulated
law official change value should be
greater than or equal to minus 1.5
after the differential gene analysis
pipeline we identified a total of 63
genes out of 24 000 gene data the gene
list of both up regulated and down
regulated genes is shown below along
with the gene symbols and gene ids
and the in symbol ids which we have
outputted from the particular pipeline
let's now look at the genes
named
as any
here we can say that this is a
different gene expression pattern that's
been expressed by the responders case as
observed in their transcripts that are
not characterized in the databases so
they are given by their in symbol ids
that we have outputted or identified or
found in our resulted data we can also
determine which genes are expressed at
different levels between conditions by
differential gene testing
these identify genes can offer
biological insight into the process
affected by the conditions of interest
now let's see
what the volcano clock shows us
the differential gene analysis process
generates a volcano plot the plot shows
us
that the x-axis indicates log-to-fold
change the y axis represent the p
adjusted value the red dots on the plot
represents significant genes the blue
dots represent the non-significant genes
the red dots with gene names represent
the most significant genes
after the related genes in the samples
are represented on the left side of the
x-axis whereas down related genes are
represented on the right side of the
x-axis
this slide contains the screenshot of
the volcano plot along with the
differentially expressed streams
found highly significant genes are
responsible for the activities
and the reasons of course
of the disease to which they associated
with which in this project is breast
cancer
you can see the genes that we obtained
with the red dots
now let's move on to the geoengineering
analysis results
first let's talk about the dot plot
we can observe that the plot contains
the geo terms on the y-axis that are
correlated to the dots the significant
score or p adjusted value for enrichment
of genes in the geo terms is shown by
the color of the dot
the
color red donates more elements whereas
the color blue
donates
let's relevance
the number of the genes in the geo term
is represented by the size of the dots
the larger the dot the more genes are
present the smaller plot the less genes
are found in a certain geo category
in the csv file that we obtain
we can likewise see explicit qualities
related with each term and accurately
adjusted values
these are the plots that were outputted
some tumors have mutations that are
typically observed in the cells certain
mutations in cells can be used to
confirm cancer diagnosis gene
identification also aids in the
development of innovative cancer
therapies and diagnosis researches so we
can conclude by saying that the various
clause graphs and outputted data files
obtained
show us the various relationships and
activities of the highly significant
genes in breast cancer cell lines
cultured with bone marrow micro
environment and this information and
data can be useful in predicting various
things about the disease and thus helps
us in their study
thank you